[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
metri Serien in allen einen schönen
guten Abend den Sport hat später Sven in
der Sendung mit viel Fußball schönen
guten Abend dann blicken wir jetzt auf
die Themen an diesem Samstag
Kritik an neuen heizungsvorgaben trotz
der Ausnahmeregelungen warnt die
Opposition vor hohen Belastungen
Ukraine Streit im Weltsicherheitsrat
ausgerechnet jetzt übernimmt Russland
den Vorsitz in den UN-Gremium
und runder Geburtstag 60 Jahre ZDF eine
Zeitreise durch die Geschichte der heute
Nachrichten
[Musik]
aufatmen bei vielen Hausbesitzern die
Ampel hat ihre Pläne fürs künftige
heizen geändert der zwangstausch von
noch funktionierenden Heizungen ist
demnach vom Tisch die Opposition hat für
den Gesetzentwurf der Regierung trotzdem
wenig übrig dazu gleich mehr zuvor
Christina gründgen über die Einigung zu
Gas und Ölheizungen bei der es diverse
Ausnahmen und Übergangsfristen gibt
neu eingebauter Heizungen sollen ab dem
1 Januar 2024 zu 65 Prozent mit
erneuerbaren Energien betrieben werden
das kann aber muss keine Wärmepumpe sein
auch andere umweltfreundliche Heizarten
und Kombinationen sind möglich und es
gibt Übergangsfristen geht eine
bestehende Gas- oder Ölheizung ihrer
Parabel kaputt darf übergangsweise
wieder eine solche eingebaut werden sie
muss aber bin in drei Jahren
nachgerüstet werden um die 65% Vorgabe
zu erfüllen auch Ausnahmen sind
vorgesehen unter anderem für
Hausbesitzer die älter als 80 Jahre sind
erst wenn das Haus verkauft oder vererbt
wird müssen die neuen Vorgaben erfüllt
werden eine weitere Ausnahme soll die
Wirtschaftlichkeit sein etwa wenn die
Umbaukosten in keinem angemessenen
Verhältnis zum Gebäudewert stehen
der Umstieg soll finanziell gefördert
werden wie genau ist aber noch unklar
ja und genau diese Unklarheit in Sachen
Förderung kritisiert die Union und
spricht auch von Klimaschutz mit der
Brechstange kritik kommt auch von der
Linkspartei die einen weiteren Beleg für
die soziale Kälte der Ampel sieht auch
die AFD kritisiert die Regierungspläne
als nicht umsetzbar mehr von Karl
Hinterleitner es war ein hartes
stückkoalitionsarbeit bis zur Einigung
am Ende kam die Regierung doch noch
zusammen beim Thema Heizen das Ergebnis
ein Kompromiss zur Wärmewelle die Grünen
zeigen sich zufrieden es ist sehr gut
dass wir die Einigung die im
Koalitionsausschuss getroffen haben
jetzt innerhalb von wenigen Tagen
umsetzen das heißt die ganze Regierung
stellt sich hinter das Vorhaben von
Robert Habeck und Lara Gallwitz das hat
2024 keine neuen Öl und Gasheizung mehr
eingebaut werden sollen sondern wir hier
auf klimafreundliche und auf bezahlbare
Alternativen setzen gerade die
Bezahlbarkeit aber wurde gestern nicht
geklärt denn wer wie viel Zuschüsse
bekommt ist immer noch offen das sei
unausgegoren und zu kurz gegriffen meint
die Opposition
dann brauchen wir eine besondere
Förderung besondere Zuschüsse für
Menschen mit geringem Einkommen die
Schwierigkeiten einfach haben so eine
Investition zu schultern da geht es ja
um Tausende von Euro da braucht es
besondere Unterstützung und da kennen
wir große Worte Olaf Schulz im Bundestag
keiner wird im Stich gelassen aber wir
kennen kein Konzept das wird gesagt dass
irgendwie sozial abgefedert werden muss
aber es wird nicht gesagt wie aber was
natürlich notwendig ist sind direkte
Zuschüsse Förderprogramme die Menschen
dürfen damit nicht allein gelassen
werden das darf nicht die Mieterinnen
und Mieter am Ende auf die umgelegt
werden für die AFD ist die ganze
wärmewende unrealistisch sie sei im
geplanten Zeitraum gar nicht machbar ja
es ist es falsch so lange in der
Situation in der wir sind wir haben
nicht wir haben die Handwerker nicht wir
haben die Wärmepumpen nicht wir haben
die technischen Lösungen nicht wir haben
nicht genügend Strom und es kommt
einfach viel zu schnell doch fürs
endgültige Aus der fossilen Brennstoffe
bleibt noch Zeit hier ist 2045 ist mit
dem Heizen mit Öl und Gas definitiv
Schluss
trotz des Krieges in der Ukraine hatte
Russland Turnus gemäß den Vorsitz des
UN-Sicherheitsrates übernommen
international gibt es Kritik an diesem
Automatismus Kiew sprach von einem
weiteren Schlag gegen geregelte
internationale Beziehungen bei einer
Sitzung des Sicherheitsrates
Verurteilten westliche Vertreter die
Pläne Moskau in Belarus taktische
Atomwaffen zu stationieren selbst China
distanzierte sich von diesem Vorhaben
allerdings ohne Russland dabei zu nennen
wir gehen jetzt zu Johannes Hano nach
New York Johannes der Welt
Sicherheitsrat soll dafür sorgen den
Weltfrieden zu wahren Russland übernimmt
jetzt wieder den Vorsitz was sagt das
über das Gremium aus
ja das sagt erstmal aus und das bedeutet
dass der Welt Sicherheitsrat seinen
eigenen Regeln folgt aber an diesen
Regeln ist massive Kritik laut geworden
es werden Reformen gefordert und das
Hauptargument ist das ist ja wohl nicht
sein könnte dass ein permanentes
Mitglied des Sicherheitsrates dass ich
verpflichtet hat den Weltfrieden zu
schützen die Kater der Vereinten
Nationen zu schützen sich für Frieden
und Sicherheit einzusetzen diese Kater
permanent bricht und ein
völkerrechtswidrigen Angriffskrieg gegen
ein Mitgliedstaat führt mittlerweile
haben sich selbst die USA die ja immer
gegen eine Reform des
sicherheitsratswahlen offen gezeigt für
eine solche Reform und in einem ersten
Schritt hat die Generalversammlung der
Vereinten Nationen beschlossen dass ich
diese Mitgliedstaaten die betonmächte
jetzt rechtfertigen müssen öffentlich
wenn Sie ein Veto einlegen das ist nur
ein kleiner erster Schritt aber immerhin
es ist ein erster Schritt da bewegt sich
etwas für den kommenden Monat wird
erwartet dass Russland versuchen wird
die er gerne zu dominieren der russische
Botschafter hat schon mal gesagt dass
man sich um die Situation der Kinder in
der Ukraine kümmern will dass man noch
mal Nord Stream auf die Agenda heben
will und das am Ende des Monats der
russische Außenminister Labor auf selbst
hier den Vorsitz übernehmen wird in
einer Sitzung und seine Vision über eine
gerechte und Einhaltung der Vereinten
Nation der Karte der Vereinten Nation
sprechen will dass dabei was
substanziell ist dabei herauskommt davon
geht hier niemand auszuweit sind die
Positionen da auseinander live aus New
York Johannes Hano vielen Dank
die Vogelgrippe grassiert derzeit in
bislang nicht bekanntem Ausmaß und das
weltweit dabei trifft es immer mehr
Arten das Virus infiziert und tötet
Hühner genauso wie Robben Füchse
Grizzlys und vereinzelt sogar Menschen
und verändert sich dabei laufend auch
die Forscher des tierseuchen-instituts
des Bundes sind beunruhigt Susanne
Seidel
gemagert und schwer atmend liegt dieser
Seelöwe an der Küste Perus im Sterben er
hat sich mit dem Vogelgrippevirus H5 N1
angesteckt sowie mehr als 600 weitere
Robben in den vergangenen Wochen in Peru
noch ist nicht klar ob jede dieser
Robben ein erkrankten Vogel fraß oder ob
der Erreger bereits unter ihnen
zirkuliert sich also an Säugetiere
angepasst hat das Virus muss bei so
einem würzwechseln ganz viele Barrieren
überwinden um wirklich sich an eine neue
wirtsart an den Menschen an eine Robbe
oder an den Fuchs anpassen zu können
genau das ist im vergangenen Oktober auf
einer Nerzfarm in Spanien passiert mehr
als 50.000 Tiere hatten sich gegenseitig
angesteckt alle wurden getötet um eine
weitere Verbreitung zu verhindern in
sehr seltenen Fällen erkranken und
sterben auch Menschen am
Vogelgrippevirus meist in Asien wie
zuletzt eine Elfjährige in Kambodscha
das Mädchen hatte engen Kontakt zu
Erkrankten wechseln nur so ist es
überhaupt möglich sich anzustecken in
den vergangenen 20 Jahren sind insgesamt
weltweit ca 450 Menschen an Vogelgrippe
gestorben
das Virus ist nach wie vor nichts sehr
gut übertragbar auf den Menschen das ist
die gute Nachricht und dass wir es
vermehrt Fälle vielleicht auch bei
Menschen finden liegt auch daran dass
wir besseres zur wählen also bessere
Überwachung der Situation weltweit aber
insbesondere in Europa haben im Moment
wütet das Virus H5 N1 vor allem in
Südamerika viele Vogelarten fallen ihm
zum Opfer dem Behörden weltweit bleibt
nur jeden Ausbruch von Vogelgrippe im
Keim zu ersticken
jetzt nach Portugal wo die Schuldenkrise
überwunden wurde auch mit viel Kapital
aus dem Ausland aber die Schattenseiten
die werden immer deutlicher dass
Milliarden in den Immobilienmarkt
flossen hat nämlich dramatische Folgen
für viele Einheimische sie können sich
keine Bleibe mehr leisten ein Recht auf
wohnen dafür demonstrierten heute 10.000
im gesamten Land Thomas Walde berichtet
in mehreren Städten Portugals wie hier
in Lissabon gegen tausende meist junge
Menschen auf die Straße sie wollen ein
Dach über dem Kopf
wir haben eine Notsituation auf dem
Wohnungsmarkt die Häuser sind voll die
Preise verrückt
[Musik]
wir verlieren das rechten unseren
Städten zu leben
Paula Fernandez verlor ihre Wohnung als
ihr Vermieter die in eine Ferienwohnung
umwandelte heute hat die Köchin mit
anderen in ähnlicher Lage dieses Haus
besetzt
die Stadt hat viele leerstehende Häuser
sie will uns die Häuser nicht zur
Verfügung stellen daraus sollen nur
Ferienwohnungen werden für Touristen für
Leute von außerhalb wir Portugiesen
bekommen keine Häuser
A 11 Ferienwohnung das ist für Vermieter
lukrativer der Durchschnittslohn von
1300 € brutto im Monat ist zu wenig und
mit Touristen zu konkurrieren oder
Ausländern die von hier aus online
arbeiten oder die durch goldene Visa
gelockt wurden also Bleiberecht gegen
Immobilien Investition
ist einer von 10.000 Amerikanern die von
dieser Möglichkeit profitiert haben
das Programm der goldenen Visa war
ursprünglich geschaffen damit verfallene
Häuser wieder hier gerichtet werden aber
jetzt hat es beinahe eine
Spekulationsblase geschaffen
als Regierung will die goldenen Visa
zurückfahren das reicht den
Demonstranten nicht sie fordern
staatliche Eingriffe in den Mietmarkt
damit Portugals Wohnungen auch für
Portugiesen wieder erschwinglich werden
in den USA hat eine Sturmfront mit
mehreren Tornados schwere Schäden
angerichtet mindestens sechs Menschen
kamen ums Leben betroffen sind mehrere
Bundesstaaten im Süden und mittleren
Westen Häuser wurden zerstört Bäume
entwurzelt 10.000 Haushalte waren
zeitweise ohne Strom in einem Theater in
Illinois stürzte während eines Konzertes
das Dach ein mindestens 30 Menschen
wurden verletzt
heute feiern wir Jubiläum denn sie
wissen es vermutlich genau vor 60 Jahren
begann das ZDF zu senden und wir nehmen
Sie jetzt einmal mit in diese erste Zeit
als teils baufällige Sendezentrale
diente ein ehemaliger Bauernhof in
Eschborn bei Frankfurt am Main und zwar
ein Jahr lang im spartanischen
Nachrichten Studio da gab es damals
schon einen Platz für die
Kurznachrichten und einen für den
hauptmoderator und damals wie heute
saßen hier immer auch Redakteure am
Mikrofon und das hier das war die
Verbindung in die Welt nach draußen man
hat mit den Kolleginnen und Kollegen in
London Washington und Paris gesprochen
so war das damals am 1 April 1963
startete das ZDF um 19:30 Uhr mit der
allerersten Sendung den heute
Nachrichten Jürgen Kehl mit einem Blick
auf früher und heute
heute
Regierungsbildung in Mainz mit
Fragezeichen
heute
Jubiläumssitzung in Brüssel ohne
Optimismus
heute die Eierpreise bis Ostern stabil
guten Abend meine Damen und Herren so
hat das mal angefangen Redakteur im
Studio Karl weiß wird bei der Premiere
noch etwas verkrampft kaum ein ZDF
Nachrichten Pionier bringt Kamera
Erfahrungen mit nach Eschborn mühsam der
Weg in die neue Fernsehwelt
improvisieren war angesagt ein
notdürftig zusammengezimmertes Studium
muss zunächst genügen die neue Redaktion
führt Rudolf Radtke der Auftrag
Fernsehnachrichten eine Alternative für
die Institution Tagesschau und dieser
Alternative suchten wir indem wir uns
vorstellten den Nachrichtenbereich
natürlich so korrekt und so von den
Tatsachen herkommen zu gestalten wie das
bei der Tagesschau auch war aber
außerdem noch stärker in den Hintergrund
der Ereignisse zu gehen
Karl weiss und die heute holen das
Weltgeschehen ins ZDF schicken Reporter
los
denn die Absturzstelle liegt mitten in
einem Sumpfgebiet das von den wird Kong
infiltriert ist Deutschland erlebt eine
neue Zeit die Gesellschaft wandelt sich
und auch die heute wagt was etwas
Ungeheuerliches Wiebke Bruns und
Kollegen 1971 als erste Frau im
bundesdeutschen Fernsehen präsentiert
sie die Nachrichten also ich hatte den
heiligen Hallen der Nachrichten von der
Frau betreten auch nur waren Skandal es
war wirklich ein Skandal erst in
Wiesbaden dann im zdf-hauptsitz in Mainz
die heute Redaktion bleibt täglich
gefordert als unabhängiger Chronist der
Zeit als schnelle und verlässliche
Quelle für Millionen Zuschauer rund um
die Uhr immer die Fragen was wählen wir
aus was zeigen wir wie die Ereignisse
kann man kaum vorhersehen man muss dran
bleiben und nur ganz ganz selten halten
alle den Atem an
das ist eine Kriegserklärung an die USA
einen guten Abend mag man sich da kaum
wünschen die heute produziert rund 3000
ZDF-Sendungen im Jahr 19 Uhr sind im
Schnitt fast 4 Millionen Zuschauer dabei
von außen ist ja nicht zu sehen wie
viele Menschen an dieser Sendung
beteiligt sind und wie wichtig es ist
dass jeder Einzelne seine Rolle erfüllt
das ist eine absolute
Mannschaftsleistung und wir dürfen die
dann präsentieren auch in der virtuellen
Welt in der Transportflieger A400M kommt
mit vier Jahren Verspätung im
Nachrichtenstudio entsteht ein Abbild
der Realität der Computer hilft den
Problemen auf den Grund zu gehen in den
vergangenen Jahrzehnten erfindet sich
das nachrichtenfernsehen immer wieder
neu immer auf Höhe der Zeit aber eines
bleibt am Ende folgt immer der Blick auf
das Wetter wie vor 60 Jahren
meine Damen und Herren hören wir uns
weiterhin in unsere Mäntel und warten
wir bessere das heißt wärmere Zeiten ab
[Musik]
Wetter gibt es dann später hier im ZDF
feiern wir das Jubiläum um 20:15 Uhr
weiter mitten im Mix aus berühmten ZDF
showklassikern in der Show der Shows und
wenn Sie unser erstes heute
Nachrichtenstudio einmal zu Hause
erleben wollen dann klicken Sie sich
einfach durch unsere interaktive
3D-Grafik in der ZDF heute App eine
Zeitreise in Schwarz-Weiß mit der
Technik von damals zum ausprobieren
so jetzt zum Fußballer dreht sich alles
um das Topspiel Bayern gegen Dortmund
Sven ja schließlich geht es zwischen dem
Tabellen ersten Dortmund und Verfolger
Bayern um die bessere Ausgangsposition
im Titelkampf kurz vor der Halbzeit
führen die Bayern mit drei zu null die
weiteren Top Teams waren heute
Nachmittag schon im Einsatz Union Berlin
schlägt den VfB Stuttgart Freiburg
Hertha Unentschieden Leipzig verliert zu
Hause gegen Mainz Schalke unterliegt
Leverkusen Wolfsburg und Augsburg ohne
Sieger und gerade läuft das Duell
zweiter gegen erster gestern bereits das
Unentschieden zwischen Frankfurt und
Bochum und morgen noch zwei weitere
Spiele in der Tabelle bleibt Union
Berlin am spitzen du dran dahinter
Freiburg und Leipzig mit Dämpfern im
Kampf um die Champions League Plätze
Leverkusen und Mainz klettern auf sieben
und acht Augsburg
und alles zur Bundesliga mit den ersten
Bildern im Free TV zum Abendspiel Bayern
gegen Dortmund gibt's gegen 23 Uhr im
Aktuellen Sportstudio mit Katrin Müller
Hohenstein zu Gast Eintracht Sportchef
markus Krösche
das Topspiel in der englischen Premier
League hat Meister Manchester City
deutlich gegen den FC Liverpool gewonnen
dabei musste der Tabellenzweiter einen
frühen Rückstand aufholen und das Team
von Jürgen Klopp zu schlagen
die beiden Trainer pep Guardiola und
Jürgen Klopp sehen nach 17 Minuten wie
die bis dahin fast nur defensiven
Liverpooler Gäste durch den Ägypter
Salah völlig überraschend mit 1 zu 0 in
Führung gehen
10 Minuten später antwortet man City mit
einer wunderbaren waldstafette die der
argentinia Julian Alvarez mit dem 1:1
für die Gastgeber abschließt kaum eine
Minute nach der Pause schießt der
überragende Kevin de Bruyne Manchester
erstmals in Führung und nur 8 Minuten
später trifft sich die Steam Captain
Ilka Gündogan zum 3:1 für den englischen
Meister ein herrliches Zusammenspiel
zwischen de Bruyne und Jack willish kann
letzterer nach 74 Minuten zum 4:1
Endstand veredelt Manchester City damit
hinter dem FCA weiter auf Tabellenplatz
große Ehre für Basketball-Legende Dirk
Nowitzki der NBA Champion von 2011 wird
in die Hall of Fame die sogenannte
Ruhmeshalle des amerikanischen
Basketballsports aufgenommen der heute
44-Jährige spielte bis zu seinem
Karriereende 2019 bei den Dallas
Mavericks und gilt bis heute als einer
der besten Spieler seiner Generation der
gebürtige Würzburger erzielte insgesamt
mehr als 31.000 Punkte und liegt damit
auf Platz sechs der ewigen Bestenliste
der hat's verdient Mitri allerdings
danke schön Sven der Deutsche
Wetterdienst warnt vor ergiebigem
Dauerregen in Teilen von
Nordrhein-Westfalen Hessen und
Baden-Württemberg wie viel Regen zu
erwarten ist das erfahren Sie gleich von
Katja horneffer gegen 22:45 Uhr ist
heute journal mit Anne Gellinek von uns
war das schönen Dank schönen Abend und
bis morgen wenn Sie mögen
[Musik]
guten Abend in den vergangenen Tagen hat
das deutschlandweit so 10 bis 50 Liter
Regen pro Quadratmeter gegeben und bis
morgen Abend kommen besonders im Stau
der westlichen Mittelgebirge aber auch
im Schwarzwald und im Allgäu noch mal 60
bis 80 Liter pro Quadratmeter dazu das
hängt zusammen mit diesem Tiefe über
Westdeutschland das bringt Regen mit und
für Sie rosa eingefärbt noch etwas
Schnee morgen übernimmt dann immer mehr
das Hoch Meryem sie wissen ja schon das
ZDF wird heute 60 und auch vor 60 Jahren
gab es einen Wetterbericht damals wurde
mit Kreide auf Tafeln gemalt Farbe gab
es im Studio nicht Wetter aber schon
heute Nacht gibt's also eine
sterbenhimmel in Norddeutschland sonst
Dauerregen im Süden und die Temperaturen
sinken im Süden unter dem Dauerregen auf
acht bis zwei Grad kälter wird es im
Norden mit +3 bis -1 Grad und morgen
liegen die Höchsttemperaturen zwischen 4
Grad im Vogtland und 12 Grad am
Oberrhein und von Norden setzt sich
morgen immer häufiger die Sonne durch
Regen und Schnee Regenwolken ziehen sich
immer mehr in den Süden zurück und die
neue Woche startet kalt aber doch meist
sonnig schönen Abend und bis bald in
Farbe